this is a nation without a functioning
government where gang violence is so
prevalent that people are forced to hide
many are fearful of kidnappings in
neighborhoods where gangs appear to have
total control
the state is going from bad to worse the
situation of the people is worsening
it's becoming overwhelming for us
haitians there is no hope for us
especially in the young people
adding to the sense of insecurity is yet
another painstaking recovery from an
earthquake in august that claimed over
two thousand lives
prime minister ariel henry is now under
intense pressure to hold elections and
rebuild the legislature but that won't
happen until sometime next year after he
dismissed haiti's electoral council
saying they were too partisan
the biggest challenge is that i have to
face the challenge of mistrust
people don't believe what is being said
we have very specific objectives to hold
elections
plans are now in place to hold a
referendum on changes to the
constitution with the hope that a
general election will soon follow
we can't talk about elections when we
have armed groups all around the country
we can't talk about elections when we
have political prisoners elections not
possible when the majority of the people
are dying from hunger
compounding the turmoil is the forced
repatriation of haitians from the u.s
mexico border
many resettled in other countries years
ago and don't want to be back
[Music]
i have five children total i left the
country a while ago i lost track of
everything i don't know what to do now
because i have no money to pay for what
i need to do i don't know if i'm going
to be stuck here or if i'll be able to
make it back to brazil
it's not entirely clear what the u.s
policy towards haiti is the biden
administration has been pushing for
elections but critics say their approach
is vague the u.s special envoy who
resigned days ago said their policies
are deeply flawed
here in florida governor ron desantis
has issued an executive order making it
harder for haitians to resettle in this
state
the investigation into the so-called
mastermind behind july's assassination
of president juvenal muis is still
ongoing
his death the spark that set off a power
struggle leaving haiti once again in a
precarious position andy gallacher al
jazeera